it was in the news not too long ago that
Ozzy had been unfaithful but I hear that
everything is okay now oh he's fine he's
fine listen it's tough you know when
you're an addict it's like he likes too
much alcohol he likes too much drugs he
likes too much sex
he likes too much food everything is too
much right so it's tough for somebody
that suffers with that that's nice so
you worked out you you worked it out
obviously you you talked to him about it
you guys decided okay it's fine it
wasn't as easy as that
no it wasn't but we worked it out after
I got him glasses and said my god you do
need glasses who would do that we got he
he now wears very thick bifocals and
he's fine that was so nicely done okay
two for one hey man you know yeah I'm
curious are you going to sometimes in a
marriage when the husband makes a
mistake
the woman will make him pay for a long
time is that something you think's going
to happen
oh yeah gonna make Ozzie pay Oh big time
yes yeah it's like he has to go
downstairs for three hours every day
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you say you like sex
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you